Joe Cox was a fresh-faced in Westminster
and from the very start
she was a uniting voice the thing that
surprises me time and time again as I
travel around the constituency is that
we are far more United and have far more
in common than that which divides us but
on the 16th of June this year she was
murdered outside a constituency surgery
in bursts all leads 53 year-old Thomas
Mayer shot and stabbed the MP he denied
it but a jury found him guilty and a
judge jailed him for the rest of his
life a few weeks ago Joe was taken from
us and our lives clapped to the world
Joe was a member of parliament and
campaigner an activist than many other
things but first and foremost she was a
sister a daughter an auntie a wife and
above all a mum to two young children
who love her with all their being all
their lives they've been enveloped in
her love excited by her energy and
inspired by her example we try now not
to focus on how unlucky we were have her
taken from us but how lucky we were have
her in our lives for so long the killing
of Joe was a political act an act of
terrorism but in the history of such
acts it was perhaps the most incompetent
and self-defeating an act driven by
hatred which instead has created an
outpouring of love an act designed to
drive communities apart which is instead
pull them together an act designed to
silence a voice which instead has
allowed millions of others to hear it
whilst we cannot always choose what
happens to us
we can try to choose how we respond I
for one will not be beaten by what has
happened and I know I am NOT alone it is
the last thing my sister would want and
it is not who I am I will channel my
energy into ensuring that Joe's legacy
continues and as a family we will
respond with strength love positivity
and enthusiasm the attack was witnessed
by passers-by one dialed 999 del on this
chaos he stabbed people had shot people
so I can see him again you can sleep I
can dream again it's got a black
baseball cap now it is walking off Brown
Hill Road now you get a police guard at
top of there and one at the bottom your
captain just minutes after police could
be seen pressing a man to the ground and
arresting him eyewitnesses said until
this moment he had been walking calmly
as Joe Cox arrived for her constituency
surgery she was attacked from behind by
Maire he shot her twice in the head and
once in the chest and in total she was
stabbed 15 times as she lay here on the
ground
Maire was hurt to have shouted Britain
first this is for Britain Britain will
always come first originally from
Scotland he'd lived most of his life on
this street not far from the murder
scene when police searched his home they
found a stash of far-right white
supremacy literature including a pin
featuring the Nazi Party emblem and a
swastika alongside another in the shape
of a skull and crossbones he'd also
watched this video explaining how to
load and fire a sawn-off shotgun when
police looked inside mayor's bag they
found a similar firearm he used hunting
bullets to kill Joe Cox the day after
the murder
Thomas Maher refused to answer any of
the questions put to him by interviewing
detectives brace probably want to know
why you've done it
Joe Cox is from they want to know why
she's dead you commit an act in a very
public place in a very public manner
which says towards that you want you
want people to know that you've done it
I was just asking you what it is why is
that message why have you done this as a
family we will not respond to hatred
with hatred we will love like Joe did
and know that although she is dead the
ideas and values that she held so dear
will live on and know that although she
is not with us her energy and her love
hardwired into our children for the rest
of their lives
her compassion for others and her stance
on refugees and immigration attracted
the attention of those with sinister
extreme views and she paid the ultimate
price for that Nick Martin Sky News
burst 'l